tonight the right-hander jake maria
signed as a free agent last month he's
worked only eight innings all year four
in his only start which was monday in st
louis looked good against the cardinals
in that start gave up one run on three
hits in his four innings of work he
struck out eight batters total in his
eight innings and only walked once
looks at a curveball kind of buckled
yastrenski that time and free gets his
first down
it's a real downer curveball doesn't
have a lot of lateral side to side
movement but breaks straight down toward
the ground out of that short arm
delivery drops it right there on the
outside corner alex stickers through
that over-the-top rotation a pure 12-6
curve ball
slices this one near the line and left
peralta coming in wade is at third and
he will hold up there david gets it back
in quickly
and faria gets a big out number two
[Applause]
on the ground to third cabrera
jake forreal walks the high wire leaves
him loaded puts a zero on the board take
a look at what sami long has done four
appearances 495 era
great strikeout ranking ratio 19
strikeouts against six walks in 20
innings d-backs now with an opportunity
two men on one man out
fastball struck him out
set that up beautifully with two
change-ups
two change-ups at 81 on the outside
corner of any 94s into the same location
rojas at third cabrera at second two
down full count
and he struck it out with the big hook
each team with a first inning threat no
runs get your 50 50 raffle tickets
dbacks.com
5050 raffle
winning number coming up on the post
game show that's a fair ball walker
collides with a first base some jeremy
rehack and they still managed to get
stephen duggar
rehack was setting a moving pick right
there
and walker worked around it little
screen and roll kind of a deal nice job
to stay with it right there and a good
job by ferrea to continue on to first
base but only four home runs he does
have six triples 17 doubles
struck him out swinging
fastball slider slider and i think
peralta is still looking for the
curveball lauren show hitting 159 and 63
at bats
in the air to left over toward the line
dickerson
and it's a three up three down inning
and we're heading
to the third top of the order wade
estrada yostremski coming up
feet to left field david peralta on the
warning track
six in a row retired by jake faria yaz
was called out on strikes after he hit a
foul ball home run
that ball
is fair
way back there
goodbye
so yazz
with his 12th home run of the year and
it's two nothing giants
sometimes you just kind of know
something's coming and that was one of
those times
that swing in the first inning was too
good he was seeing the ball too big
and he was not going to wait around this
time absolutely blasted one one ball no
strikes
curve ball
deep left center still going still going
and dropped
the two of them came together peralta
got the glove on it
dickerson around third crawford heading
for third standing
three-nothing giants
he hit it
to the deepest part of the ballpark it's
413 feet to that spot and really i
thought this was going to be
smith's ball in center field and peralta
comes over
from left field and takes charge and he
got a lot of glove on this thing you
expect a gold glover to make that play
that that's got to be hey
that's got to be an
error is a base hit to right field just
in front of the on rushing
josh reddick crawford in to score four
nothing giants
under the glove of estrada
that gets all the way to the wall it
gets behind dickerson
and how about jake faria lead off double
work begins on making up that
four-nothing deficit first ever hit for
jay korea as a professional baseball
player and he has not thrown a curveball
and that pitch is definitely set up here
and that's the current ball for the
strikeout
nice pitch calling out there mike
durable cabrera has been among the most
effective d-backs bats as of late he's
singled his first time up tonight
off the middle and throw in the center
maria coming around third no throw
diamondbacks on the board
walker knocks it into right field ahmed
coming around
cabrera into third that's where they
throw it
and he's in there walker at second it's
four to two
there you see him number 53
he's the possible tying run
the curveball and that is a swinging
strike three so he gets through it with
just the two runs
[Applause]
the smasher smashes one deep to right
center
andrew young hits gets stuck in the wall
he's just going to keep on going maybe
they won't notice
he's going to have to go back
[Music]
got stuck between the pads out in front
of the pool on the fly andrew young
nick has singled and walked tonight
in the lead off spot
fly ball deep right field yostremski
backing up at the wall let's go
nick of it follows andrew young back to
back two out hits and we are all tied at
four
well he put nick in there in the lead
off spot against the left-hander he has
singled walked in homer
david so far over two struck out twice
against the lefty sammy long
peralta little bloop trying to get down
and it drops in
cabrera's home and it's five four
diamondbacks
just enough to get it by solano
[Applause]
carcio breaks his bat little squib shot
crawford
what a play to get him at first
huge for brandon crawford the gold glove
defense at shortstop that was
spectacular
center field pavon smith out there
trying to drop in and a sliding grab by
david peralta
slicing away from pavement into shallow
left center of the freight train got on
the tracks
go get it david perrault a little jam
shot that time
david the only guy that had a chance
right there comes in with a slide makes
a nice catch
what a boy
so now austin slater giants down by a
run 8th inning
hit deep
left center field way back there
[Music]
and that
is the first home run in a while for
austin slater
and it has to feel oh so good and the
giants have gone ahead
six to five
left field and jalen davis lays out
two down
tyler rogers is going to be buying a few
breakfasts tomorrow that's a great play
and the only way you get this is if you
get
a good jump
and he does
smith facing mcgee for the first time
strike three called outside corner
98 miles an hour and the ball game is
over